I am a victim of a hate
crime Stanley knows what I'm talking
about that's not what a hate crime is
well I hated it a lot okay I you're a
good guy you too Michael appears to be
gay too and yet he is my
friend I guess I do have a gay friend
you know what I'm going to raise the
stakes you don't we don't I want you to
watch
this and I want you to burn this into
your
brains I don't think we because this is
an
image that I want you people to remember
for a long time to come whenever you
come into the office I want you to think
about this we don't need to yes we do
what
I did
it thank you thank you thank you
see I'm still
here we're all still
here oh come on Dwight come on man it's
only Meredith yeah it's only Meredith
thank God but did you see the way they
looked at me
like I was a murderer or something
hey why did you do it it was an accident
was she talking back no she got sick of
that face did she owe you money uh-oh is
this downsizing did she spurn your
advances I have already put down the
deposit do you understand how a deposit
Works Mike I am not having fire eaters
in a paper warehouse It's casino night
like Las Vegas there fire readers all
over the place except my warehouse well
actually it's my warehouse actually it's
owned by beakman properties and Dunder
Mifflin is four years into a 7-year
lease why are you here when darl was
coming you said you wanted me here for
protection that I said not that there's
this guy he's at a nymphomaniac
convention and he is psych CU all these
women are smoking hot perfect tens
except for this one chick who looks a
lot like U us no no no no no that
crosses the line exqueeze
me not you
Kevin just
unwarranted hostile work environment
Kevin well Packer said it no you said it
he pointed a point is not a say look
Kevin we are a family here and Phyllis
is a valued member of that family like a
grandmother I'm the same age as you
Michael I don't know about that we're
the same high school well I have a late
birthday and usually September is a cut
off point you know what you just crossed
the line okay there's a line and you
went over it and you must be punished so
go to your corner you mean where my desk
is yes your corner go okay I have a lot
of work to do anyway oh my they really
got to you didn't they they didn't get
to
me I got to
them I am still the same old Michael
Scott new and improved
you know what I love
Phyllis you know what
else I think she is gorgeous I think she
is an incredibly incredibly attractive
person come here give me a come on
Michael come on you don't have to worry
I'm not report I'm not worried HR you
know what the only thing I am worried
about is getting a
boner good work today today
everybody times have changed a
little and even though we're still a
family here at Dunder Mifflin families
grow and at some point the daddy can't
take a bath with the kids
anymore I am upper management and it
would be inappropriate for me to take a
bath with Pam as much as I might want
to
[Music]
you don't want anything my treat some
panties
or got thong or
g-ring teab back get a nice bra padded
bra see-through pushup lace thigh high
bser any it just you know what I would
love to buy you a fresh set of underwear
it's just like so
creepy what's what's happening oh some
guy exposed himself to philis in the
parking
lot really is she okay yeah Bob Vance
took her for a walk to calm
down
okay Phillis you
[Music]
say what is so funny um I mean did he
even see Pam or uh Karen from behind I'm
guessing
not
I'm
sorry it's pretty funny when you think
about it oh not really no it's
disgusting and demeaning oh okay masters
of Comedy a guy dropped his pants have
you ever been to the
circus
okay he's back a
okay hey what's going on there's a
police car and them what
oh what's going on oh philis got flashed
it's
um I don't think laughing about it's a
appropriate response oh come on we
laughing at Phyllis but she's not even
here so no harm no
foul
hope this helps
Jim nice what are you doing sh don't be
scared it
works
oh
no oh bang boom shake
CL hello
everybody what are you doing fair
question I I I I sit down
hly I'll take it from
here I am
beautiful
they are
beautiful he is
beautiful this big fat pig is
beautiful it's my sumo suit I just
didn't inflated all the way I'm so glad
that I bought instead of rented body
image we are here because there is
something wrong with Society see you're
always saying there's something wrong
with Society but maybe there's something
wrong with you if it's me then Society
made me that way now I know a lot of you
are probably asking yourself why are you
dressed in a plus-size suit because
you're kind of doing Michael Clump how
do you know Michael Clump because it's
you're making fun of fat people
character how dare you Michael Clump is
a celebration of fat people hey did you
guys see this memo that Dwight sent out
women will be sent home if they wear
makeup or heels exceeding one4 inch
females are not allowed to speak to
strangers unless given written
authorization by Dwight shre this is
ridiculous attention I am removing all
bananas from the
kitchen Dwight this memo that you
distributed is insulting desperate times
call for desperate measures sleeves down
to the wrists button-up collars and
muted colors nobody dresses like that
okay you know something Dwight we are
not the terrorist why don't you just
take these women put them in a burlap
sack and hit them with a stick because
that's what you're
doing